Then the Lord rained upon Sodom and
Gomorrah,
brimstone and fire from the Lord out of
Heaven,
and he overthrew the cities and all the
plane and all the inhabitants of the
cities and that which grew up on the
ground,
but his wife looked back from behind him
and she became a pillar of salt,
known histology for catastrophe.
I think that's what that means is that
when you leave what's not good,
you wash the dust off your feet and you
don't look back,
and that's a very harsh lesson.
This is echoed a bit,
the New Testament,
the idea of the necessity for immediate
action.
These are some of the harsher words that
Christ said.
This is from Matthew Eight.
Christ is addressing a multitude and
asking people to follow him,
and a disciple comes up to him and says,
Lord,
suffer me first to go and bury my
father.
Seems like a perfectly reasonable
request,
but Jesus said unto him,
follow me,
and let the dead bury their dead.
This is from Matthew 12.
Well,
he had talked to the people.
Behold his mother and his brethren stood
without desiring to speak with him.
Then one said to him,
behold,
thy mother and I,
brethren,
stand without desiring to speak with
the,
but Jesus answered the one who was
telling him and said,
who is my mother and who is my brother's
for whosoever shall do the will of my
father,
which is in heaven,
the same as my brother and sister and
mother.
Well,
what does all that mean?
It means that there's no excuses
whatsoever for not getting up and
getting out it.
That's what it means and it means that
it even means that when people are beset
with a catastrophe,
like let's say the death of their
father,
that they are prone to use that as an
excuse for not going about the business
that they should be going about because
they can say to themselves,
well,
I would except,
and except there's always good reasons.
I mean,
believe me,
there's always good reasons for not
doing what you should.
It's for sure the reasons pile up day
after day to not do what you should,
especially cause you're,
you're aiming at things in the future.
You can put them off and definitely
right because of the demands of the day,
but these stories,
they say a variety of things,
you know,
and especially in combination.
They say when you leave somewhere
terrible,
do not look back.
There's known astrologer that's,
that's the letting the dead parts of
yourself go
and then if you're going to follow the
good,
there's no excuse not to do it and that
it means no excuse whatsoever under any
circumstances.
And then it's taken even farther.
With regards to familial relationships,
it is.
You can't even let them stand in your
way and I think that's all true and I
think I've seen virtually all of that in
my clinical practice.
Like there is no excuse whatsoever for
not getting at what it is that you
should be doing and I think there's
something else that's going on here,
especially in the new testament stories
which has even made maybe worse,
which is it's absolutely reprehensible
to justify your inaction with a
catastrophe that extract mercy from
other people.
Right?
There's a tricky,
tricky game that's going well,
of course I can't do that.
Look at the terrible thing that's just
happened to me and say,
oh,
okay,
I understand you're absolved of any
necessity to move forward because of
your current catastrophe.
It's like,
well,
actually you're not,
and it's rather rude of you to use it as
an excuse and it's certainly
counterproductive.